that women generally want men with
sexual experience
I think it depends on the person to be
honest
um I think personally yeah I prefer
someone with sexual experience probably
but I also would be with someone without
sexual experience if we connect it it
just kind of depends on the vibe is you
know do you think that women want a man
with sexual experience or no sexual
experience yeah
I mean it's not like a trick question
it's yeah it's just yeah it's an honest
question yeah but I do think it's
possible to also be with someone who
doesn't have sexual experience just
because that's my preferred because
that's what I mean a lot of things are a
lot of times like like where does this
even come up in the like do you go oh
hey I'm I've met this girl I'm gonna
maybe sleep with them oh how much like
oh they're gonna go oh how many how many
girls have you slept with oh what's the
transaction like no I think it's
conversation people I sleep with like I
actually ask every single almost every
single girl I meet and hang out I'm just
out of curiosity do you put a lot of
weight on that so if a woman has left
with a lot of like men do you say okay
I'm not gonna sleep with you just
because no I personally I love women who
in general uh and I I definitely like
hoes but I won't eat them why because uh
I don't want a woman I'm gonna be
emotionally committed to to have all
this emotional baggage from a past
relationship so it doesn't necessarily
have this is kind of what I was trying
to say before it doesn't have to equate
to emotional baggage if if a person
chooses to acknowledge it and take
accountability for the fact that they
accept a lot of people right you can
step out and what people can change
would you say in general it does
in I think General like like a girl a
girl like we had we had Linda on the
show yeah yeah this girl is so cute and
innocent she she she's 20 and a virgin
yeah like she's the cutest sweet like
she was on the last show what's her
Instagram first
and and like you could tell no baggage
no trauma like every like like joke
anyone would say like it would just go
over her head because she was so
innocent you just don't get that with
girls that have slept around a lot like
you can you can even if you don't know
their body count like you can kind of
just tell because they're more damaged
people can have damage without having
slept around you can have emotional
baggage without it being wrong
you're right you're correct you can but
I'm saying in general yeah would you say
that the virgins tend to have less
baggage than the people that did only
fans say they probably have other
baggage that's what I mean maybe less
sexual
reactions but you need to learn to
articulate them like this is because I
love it it explodes my [ __ ] mind
because this is all like I would not
even consider any one of these things a
prerequisite or a parameter for like
someone that I would potentially enter
into a relationship or have intimacy
with or like it just it's completely
[ __ ] foreign to me excuse use my
language no no like like it just it's
just completely foreign to me I would
not I like I don't understand it I've
been in polyamorous relationships I've
been like I I I I just I just like yeah
I just don't understand it it just like
I would never even be like oh hey hey
we're like hanging out for the first
time how many people have you slept with
like I just wouldn't even wouldn't even
come into my brain how often are you
meeting new dating partners
like like fair Fairly frequently so
you're not communicating with them
what's that you're not like
communicating with them but why you know
yeah of course I am okay I I think the
point is more that like body count isn't
really a part of when you say value in
communication relationships are you
saying that you're in a relationship
where the woman that you're with can
sleep with other men yeah I've been in
open relationships plenty like that's
all I was actually my question yeah I
just want to clarify yeah yeah yeah I'll
gladly clarify so the woman that you're
with is actually cool with sleeping with
other men well like you're cool with it
well like it's like it's not
particularly in this no not in this
moment but you've been in there yeah
many times many times but it's also man
that I've been able to sleep with those
people so you know what a cockhold is I
know exactly yeah that's what that would
be yeah so you've been a cuckold no no
that's nothing
it's completely consensual and it's
completely that with boundaries in place
do you have any preference is that a
curiosity in terms of what uh whether
you guys have an open relationship or
just a committed relationship
um I normally prefer an open
relationship so you prefer her being
able to sleep with other guys and maybe
she got to sleep with other people no
judgment on it I'm just curious like you
it doesn't matter to you she comes home
she got railed by three different dudes
and then she comes back says baby I love
you well I'm just like but I think
kisses you and all that if that's a
choice then and I think I think as well
with that it kind of allows her sorry
yes my masculinity isn't that fragile
I'm quiet I'm like I don't I don't know
how much masculinity you have after a
woman is you're allowing your woman to
get penises from somewhere else so how
do you define masculinity
um men are territorial creatures are
they yeah they are okay and um if my
woman yes your woman yeah yeah your
possession your possession I'm a
territory individual yeah
if the woman that I have stated that
this is mine is gonna tell me that she's
gonna go and get a penis from somewhere
else and she can just go there yes you
know what I mean you're not going to
come back but you can go and I'm saying
maybe maybe I would say that the
majority of men I think that I would be
okay in saying the majority of men would
not want their woman being [ __ ] down
by somebody else maybe that's the case
of your own masculinity being a little
bit fragile then if you're not it's
biology right we said no it's not
biology you keep using that term but I
just think men don't like wiping These
Hoes come on it's okay to sleep with
them just don't hate them I said why
like but like but like like it's like
okay because you are your habit so I
wouldn't want to date a guy that's
cheated on every single girlfriend that
he's ever had and and so I can
understand why a guy wouldn't want to
date a girl that's been sleeping around
for 10 years because it's going to be
hard to one day stop and I honestly feel
the same way a little bit about guys
because if a dude's been sleeping around
forever what are the odds I'm gonna get
him to settle down right and so like I
can understand where guys are coming
from you just guys put some really
[ __ ] weird parameters I'm just saying
the woman that you're letting go out and
sleep with other men she's not yours
she's not your woman of course she's not
mine I don't own anything
no no she's she's her own autonomous
individual person
like she's not my possession you seem to
be putting a lot of ownership onto your
onto your girlfriend you seem to be
acting like you should have a a a a a
collar around her neck and she's your
pet I mean
yeah I'm not even I'm not here for
[ __ ] King Shame don't get me wrong
don't get me wrong but you're putting a
lot of you're putting a lot of oh she is
mine whereas I'm saying No this person
that I'm with is
if I was to get married to a guy I would
feel like I'm his we'll see genuinely
like yeah I don't intend on ever getting
married I think I think it's a I think I
think the idea of marriage is quite
strange to be honest so like and I and I
get that it's not for everyone but I I
like I don't really mind the idea of
like belonging to a guy I actually kind
of like it of course yeah of course and
that's your own projective isn't it but
like but but do you want a guy
specifically saying that they control
you and that you're
I think there are levels but I would
like I would like a guy that could lead
me and make decisions for us and I would
really like that I could trust to make
decisions with your consent as well
though with with your consent on top of
that well yeah it's submission not yeah
not to just force there well I don't I
think all of I think all of the guys are
like they want a guy that or girl not a
guy a girl that wants to follow them
it's not like they wanna they want a
girl that doesn't want to be there
close but so so like I'm saying like if
if I was with a guy and he wanted to
have an open relationship on both ends I
would I would be concerned I would think
like what because I would I would trust
your judgment because I as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible